Okay.
[Silence]
Yep.
And so
it actually there were two
very lengthy
lengthier narrations are going to be
harder to follow if someone isn't paying
attention and following following up
with each of the
and so you'll find that
some of these narrations we've skipped
because they would take I mean roughly
about as much time as we spend on each
narration about a week to conclude.
if you want see those narrations then
I would
point you back to the source material
which is
not the a bridged version because there
is an abridged
printed by and others. Many authors
have tried to summarize
however the full version
authored by
has those narrations also there was a
very very long narration. It is the
longest narration
about the repentance story of Malik
in the chapter of repentance. These are
very critical stories to
understanding our religion. So I would
revert you back to those chapters.
Continuing in
the chapter
of Suduk
which is truthfulness and truth. That is
a very important combination of words
there. It is not just truthfulness. It
is truthfulness and tress. Now when we
talk about
in the Quran
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says in
what is the definition of
we gave a very simple definition that
the scholars have mentioned of them was
in his
and that is
truness
as understood from the diction of the
Quran
is that what is inside of a person's
heart
matches what is outside of a person's
heart. This is referred to as
this person is
and the opposite of that is
which is what is in the heart does not
match what is displayed on the outside.
You look for instance at the opening
verse of
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says
Allah says to the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam every time the hypocrites come
to you. They say we testify that you are
indeed the messenger of Allah. Now what
does Allah respond to that? He says
Allah knows that you are indeed his
messenger.
head
and Allah testifies in response to their
testimony that the
they are
lying they are deceive deceptful
deceptive they are lying but that
statement itself is true
few statements are more are are as true
[Arabic recitation]
That's correct. The statement itself is
true. But it Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
considered it a lie from them because
of what is in their heart. They do not
say with their tongues what they believe
with their heart. They do not believe
that he is the messenger of Allah. They
are merely saying with their tongues
that they testify that he is the
messenger of Allah. So Allah judged them
as being dishonest not because the
statement itself is incorrect but
because the statement itself does not
match their belief in their hearts.
And so we understand from this that
throughout the Quran,
in order for truth,
something to be considered true,
it has to have a couple of ingredients.
Number one, the first factor is that it
is believed by the speaker in his heart.
Number two, that the statement itself is
in accordance with reality.
Those two things together make a
statement true. They make a statement
sudok.
However, if any of those two
factors are missing, it is considered to
be falsehood.
So what does that mean? That means that
if a person is honest,
listen closely.
If a person is honest and he believes
something in his heart, but the
statement itself is wrong, it's
considered in the language of the Quran,
the language of Quraysh to be kib.
And this is well known amongst the
scholars of Islam.
For instance,
a discussion occurred between a woman
and one of her Aia
and
she
had she had a divorce that occurred
or an issue with herd
and her wii
who was called Abu Sabil. That was his
kuna. He had said that she cannot get
married again until such and such. The
exact issue is unimportant here for our
purposes.
When she came to ask the prophet
sallallah.aii alaihi wasallam. Is he
correct in this? He responded, the
prophet responded and said
Abu
it doesn't mean that he intentionally
lied.
What means in the language of the Quran,
the language of the prophet Sam
is falsehood. It's something that is
incorrect.
So it doesn't mean that Abu Sam is a bad
person and he is a liar. That's not what
is intended by the narration. What is
intended by the narration is Abu is
wrong. He is incorrect in that
statement.
Being that he is incorrect in that
statement, that statement is
and so if we understand this, we
understand that your intention is only
one of the factors
that make up what is referred to as a
sud in the Quran.
A person's intentions are only one
factor. There are other factors
involved. The statement itself has to be
correct. And second of all, it has to
match what is in the heart. It has to
believe be believed by the speaker. If
those factors are in place, then this is
considered to be a if those factors are
incorrect or any of those factors are
missing, this is considered to be kib in
the Quran. And if you understand this,
you will understand these two words in
the Quran and Sunnah much better. And
you'll be able to understand
when you come across the word
truth and falsehood in the Quran
at a deeper level.
Usually in our
in our words when we speak when we
say someone is lying or someone has lied
this means that the person
has some kind of nefarious intention,
right? This means that the person
intentionally fabricated something.
And so if we have that understanding and
then we try to understand the same words
in the Quran and Sunnah in that way we
will misunderstand the Quran and Sunnah
which is very common and that is
understanding the words of the Quran and
Sunnah with the definitions that we have
in our modern times. Those are not the
same definitions. The word may be the
same but the definitions are not the
same. Another example of this very
common example if I say for instance in
Arabic to the Arab speakers what does
the word mean
in the Arabic language people will say
is an atom right that is not at all what
it means in the Quran and Sunnah in the
Quran and Sunnah is a tiny ant that's
what it means is that a big deal yes of
course it's a big
Because if you could imagine with me the
equivalent of a person
who takes the word for instance
for instance in certain circles they
will refer to a police officer as a
what? As a pig.
Now if I took that definition and
applied it to the Quran, what would
happen? We'd have some very serious
misunderstandings there, right? That is
because when we understand the Quran,
when we understand the sunnah is very
important. This is what scholarship is.
Is studying
what these words meant 1500 years ago at
the time when they were spoken at the
time when they were revealed to the
prophet sallall.aii
Understanding this is a key to
understanding this chapter that
has given us here. It's the fourth
chapter of
the chapter of
the chapter of truthfulness and tress
both of them together. Truthfulness is
that a person when he speaks he is
truthful. But trness is that a person is
true to what he says. That is what goes
on in the heart. Both of those words are
meant in the word.
Both of those words
are what is meant in the word the Arabic
word in the Quran and
for
us.
Bye-bye.